it feels incredible to be part of the
list if you have told me a couple of
years ago that this was gonna happen I
would have told you that you have to be
lying it's it's totally unbelievable
I'm Erin Calandra and I'm the CEO of
cxeh it's a company that we do coding
and analytics tools for management
decision support in in healthcare I have
a bit of a different story to some other
entrepreneurs I actually started my
career working in finance I was not very
convinced by that and my father together
with some other partners here at started
a company that did healthcare IT and I
decided to give it a try and work for
the company and became really passionate
about health care and a firm believer of
the value of universal care and public
health care systems so I decided to go
to the US pursue an MBA in Harvard to
get more managerial skills and on my way
back to Spain I I raised some financing
bought out the company and I transform
the company and I'm looking to expand it
it's very different to just like work at
the company to use actually own the
company and and have the challenge to
transform a company looking to trying to
transform an industry as a whole so I
think it's knowing that what you're
doing is actually has an has an impact
that you're working to to transform an
industry and something that you firmly
believe in like I do for me it's public
healthcare systems and I think that some
days when you have a hard day and you
have to send wake up and just go to work
you're realizing you're doing something
that really adds value and that keeps
you going so I think it's fine something
that you're passionate about also be
very persistent in your work and also
for someone like me if you've worked in
something like finance or consulting
before to understand that working in a
start-up or at a small company that's
growing it's very different that you
have to make sometimes decisions pretty
fast and you can't have all the analysis
you want with you because otherwise
you'll get stuck in paralysis by
analysis you need to trust yourself and
you also need to be just trust your
guards
servoz next step is scaling we're
building new products for our portfolio
and we're looking to scale in in
different countries
[Music]